democrats believe they have the upper
hand on legislation
and culture and the narrative but the
blowback is already beginning i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
don't let big tech track what you do
anonymize your web browsing at
expressvpn.com
ben well we begin today with an actual
piece of good news which i know is kind
of rare these days because there's a lot
of bad news from the world of culture
the world of media and the world of
legislation
and don't worry we'll get to all the bad
news but there was one piece of news
yesterday that really stood out to me
to understand why this is a piece of
good news what you first have to
understand is what joe biden was
actually elected to do and then what he
thinks he has been elected to do
so what joe biden was actually elected
to do was be as i have termed him
president houseplant
his entire job was to be barely animate
that was his job
he he can he constructed his entire
campaign
around the notion that he was going to
be a warm body a barely above room
temperature
body as rush limbaugh might say that was
gonna be the entire thing right he's
gonna sit there he's gonna watch madlock
we're all gonna go back to normal and
that was gonna be that
most americans thought that was joe
biden's pitch he was a moderate old
gentleman who wasn't going to push
forward any sort of radical ideas but
joe biden because he's a politician
and an arrogant politician at that he
actually thinks that his mandate was to
be transformational in some way now
here's the thing about america we don't
need a massive transformation before
the coveted pandemic things at least in
economic terms were going swimmingly
we had incredible wage increases
particularly at the bottom of the
spectrum
we had the lowest unemployment rate in
50 years and things were going
swimmingly in terms of the economy so we
didn't need an economic
transformation and if we did need a
transformation in terms of sort of our
attitude toward politics what we really
needed was a cooling down
we didn't need a heating up we didn't
need more culture wars we didn't need
more radicalism
and joe biden was elected to sort of put
a stop to that right joe biden was
elected
because specifically because he was
barely alive that was basically his
campaign pitch
biden i'm barely alive and that's the
thing he's kind of good at being barely
alive because the bar is real low all
you have to do is not be dead and also
not be super alive you just have to be
barely alive and joe biden
it's like what he's qualified for he was
never he was never
any sort of great shakes mentally but
now given the fact that he is in some
pretty obvious decline the american
people saw that as in as an
asset they saw that as a feature not a
bug of joe biden
and so joe biden you know being barely
there has never impacted his popularity
ratings now people on the right are sort
of frustrated by this the fact that
joe biden is clearly not what he once
was
and again he was never at a wonderful
level to begin with
but he's clearly not what he wants was
why aren't more people turning on him
because of that the answer is he was
elected to be this
when joe biden loses his lines in the
middle of press conferences it's
disquieting on a sort of human level to
watch
a man who's clearly starting to lose it
be the most powerful
man in the free world but on another
level it's sort of comforting to know
that that person
theoretically is not going to wield
outsized power to do radical things so
for example yesterday
jovan just lost his lines he was talking
about the cove pandemic and once again
there there is a certain level of
trepidation just as a human being you
get watching joe biden again it's like
watching nick willenda
walk over a volcano like any moment here
things could go real bad
it's why people have suggested that we
ought to cut away every time joe biden
goes up or down the stairs of air force
one because we could be watching history
in real time
here's joe biden yesterday losing his
lines until this
vaccine is available to the world
and we're beating back the
vaccine the virus in other countries
we're not really completely safe
so we've made great progress
i'm still looking forward to the
prospect if we keep the pace we're on
and we listen to one another and
take the precautions i talked about that
you'll be able to have
uh a fourth of july an independence day
on july the 4th okay so again
the guy's not all that and that was the
pitch the pitch was genial
old man who's not all there but his
party believes and he believes that he's
there to be a transformational president
and so they pushed really hard on every
single front they've pushed really hard
they've pushed really hard on the
legislative front they're pushing
forward a 2 trillion dollar supposed
infrastructure bill
has nothing to do with infrastructure
only 5 percent of that bill is roads and
bridges
even if you include things like
broadband internet or plumbing because
they want to
replace some pipes even if you do that
only about one third of the bill is
dedicated to what could actually be
termed infrastructure they're just
expanding the term infrastructure to now
include everything
on planet earth they they've already
pushed forward a two trillion dollar
quote-unquote covered relief package
that radically restructures the nature
of the relationship between the
individual and the american government
it passes out checks for basically being
alive under certain circumstances
and now they're pushing forward on a
bunch of other radical proposals
they are now pushing forward for example
on this iran deal this this
is an incredibly radical thing to do
given the fact that iran has basically
been marginalized by the world community
iran is in serious trouble iran has had
to draw back within its own borders and
pursue less terrorism because of the
economic sanctions placed on them
by the trump administration meanwhile
peace has broken out in the middle east
in historic fashion with the abraham
accords israel making peace with the uae
israel making peace with morocco israel
making peace
with bahrain israel and already a sort
of cold peace with egypt
and a slightly warmer peace now with
saudi arabia and all of that is historic
stuff
the biden administration is diving in
head first to try and break all of that
up by handing some sort of concessions
to the iranian terrorist government
according to the washington post
u.s and iranian officials said tuesday
an initial day of talks in vienna and
returning to the 2015 nuclear deal where
quote unquote
constructive but the biden
administration cautioned no immediate
breakthroughs were anticipated on one of
the new president's top
foreign policy goals the european-led
diplomatic effort featured mediators
shuttling
between iranian and american envoys that
wasn't the face-to-face discussions
being held but this is all kabuki
theater
eventually biden will sign some sort of
incredibly sycophantic deal with the
iranians he'll just hand over the story
to the iranians because that's exactly
what barack obama did that's a radical
move meanwhile on the legislative
front they're going to move in a radical
direction with regard to this
2.3 trillion quote-unquote
infrastructure plan
according to the new york times a ruling
from the senate parliamentarian
parliamentarian
means democrats may be able to push
through that biden 2.3 trillion dollar
quote-unquote infrastructure plan
without any republican support
whatsoever
according to the new york times
democrats might not have to have the
votes to gut the filibuster but they
were just handed the procedural keys to
a backdoor assault
on the senate's quote unquote famous
obstruction tactic it's funny funny how
this becomes a famous obstruction tactic
when used by republicans when it's used
by democrats
it's the democrat it's it's the senate's
important procedures to protect
bipartisanship
with a ruling on monday the democrats
can reuse this year's budget blueprints
at least once to employ fast
track reconciliation democrats can now
conceivably advance multiple spending
and tax packages this year without a
single republican vote
as long as they hold their 50 members
together it is a means of weakening the
filibuster without having to take the
politically charged vote to do so the
parliamentarian parliamentarian
basically just gave them
exactly what they want senator chris van
hollen democrat of maryland said it's
always good to have a series of
insurance policies
he said this about the possibility that
democrats could just redo the party-line
passage of the two trillion dollar
virus relief legislation that passed
last month
whatever strategy they employ it's clear
that the decision by the senate
parliamentarian to agree with senator
chuck schumer democrat of new york and
majority leader that a 47 year old
budget provision could be used more than
once in a fiscal year
widens biden's path to enacting his
infrastructure plan by shielding it from
filibuster the ruling means that if
stymied by republicans on plans
they can protect under reconciliation
that applies to measures that directly
affect federal spending and revenues
democrats will have more opportunities
to move ahead on their own if they so
choose
so this is a twisting of the process of
course and they are going to continue to
push forward
these world beating proposals but here
is the encouraging news right this is
all the
this is all depressing isn't it but here
is the encouraging news
democrats have gone too far they're
starting to realize they've gone too far
but they can't stop themselves okay this
is the thelma
thelma and louise are already off the
cliff they're just realizing that they
are in mid-air right now
it's like a wily coyote cartoon where
they've run directly off the cliff they
look down and in that split second
before you get the
wiley looks directly into the camera and
realizes that he is no longer on solid
land
that's what's about to happen to the
democratic party and they're realizing
it the realization is coming into their
eyes we'll get to this
in just one second first let us talk
about keeping
your house safer and more secure and
making sure you know what's going on on
your property so much happens at your
front door that's one thing that hasn't
changed these days in my house i've been
getting groceries and food deliveries
and friends stopping by and my kids are
constantly running around our property
i need ring devices on my property
that's why the first thing my wife said
to me when we moved
was let's get ring out here and let's
put all this stuff up right now
i love having the ring video doorbell
i've actually added some ring security
cameras around the house
as well i have a bunch of the running
security cameras to make sure that i can
keep track of my three wild children
see and speak to whomever is at your
door from anywhere with the video
doorbells keep an eye on every corner of
your house with easy to install indoor
and outdoor cams protect your whole home
with ring alarm it's a powerful
affordable whole home security system
you can easily install yourself
right now get a special offer on the
ring welcome kit at ring.com
ben it comes with that ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro it's the
perfect way to upgrade your front door
and start your ring experience head on
over to ring.com
that is ring.com band go check them out
right now
ring dot com slash ben and get a special
offer on that ring
welcome kit to today ring.com we love
ring you will too
alrighty so here is the good news that i
have promised
again the biden administration is
starting to realize that they are not
standing on solid ground anymore so
for example this administration has
pushed an open borders policy
that's the reason why you have seen this
massive increase in the amounts of
illegal immigration across the border
it's why i've seen the surge of migrant
children because they basically said
doors wide open and guess what
people took advantage of the wide open
door
there's a candy store it now has a sign
in the front window that says free candy
inside
shockingly many people are arriving to
take the free candy that's not the fault
of the people trying to get in
it's the fault of the people who put out
the sign because those people are stupid
the biden administration has taken the
world's worst immigration policy then
they put kamala harris in charge of it
kamala harris has not been down to the
board once kamala harris has not held
the press conference on immigration
policy maybe that's because
she's been a pro open borders advocate
for years kamala harris
is a completely ineffective leader she's
a bad politician
and putting her in charge of the border
makes no sense whatsoever but no one's
in charge of the border is the actual
answer so what does that mean
well apparently what it means is that
the biden administration
is now secretly having to reinstall all
of the old trump administration policies
remember those evil policies
the discriminatory policies against
against people south of the war
so terrible fascistic nazi-esque
according to the uk independent
construction on donald trump's border
wall may continue under joe biden's
administration
department of homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas told
department employees he might be green
lighting work on the wall to plug gaps
in the current wall new york has
reportedly said it's not a single answer
to a single question
there are different projects the chief
of border patrol has presented and the
acting commissioner of cbp presented to
me
the president has communicated quite
clearly his decision that the emergency
that triggered the devotion of dod funds
to the construction of the border wall
has ended
but that does leave room to make
decisions as the administration as part
of the administration in particular
areas of the wall that need renovation
particular projects that need to be
finished
so in other words he's just going to do
what trump did but he's going to call it
something different
here's jen sackey acknowledging that
some of the construction has already
been funded
and uh yeah probably we're going to be
doing some of that evil trump wall
wall construction remains paused to the
extent permitted by law so some
has already been funded through uh
congressional uh authorization
and funding allocation uh but as
agencies uh develop for a plan
it's paused while agencies are
developing developing a plan for the
president
on the management of the federal funds
it is paused uh there is
some limited construction that has been
funded and allocated for but it is
otherwise paused okay otherwise it is
paused
otherwise except it's not paused except
that they are going to be building wall
okay so they've they're starting to
realize that they went too far on the
border
they're also beginning to realize that
they've gone too far with regard to the
corporate bullying
so the administration is never going to
admit that they just lied they did they
lied over and over about the georgia law
joe biden said yesterday that it was a
jim crow voting law which is just
ridiculous
it is the most ridiculous comparison
this side of
something i don't like is the holocaust
right is is that this thing i don't like
is jim crow and biden uses it repeatedly
biden's old enough to remember jim crow
i mean biden's almost old enough to
remember slavery in america but he's old
enough to remember jim crow for sure
so he should certainly know the
difference between jim crow you know
like separate water fountains for black
people
and open suppression of the vote in the
south people getting
fire hosed for trying to express their
their desire for individual rights
he you should remember that that is not
the georgia voting law it doesn't matter
he's a damned liar so he keeps repeating
that over and over here was jen sackey
saying that georgia had made it harder
to vote despite the fact that in most
counties it expanded voting hours
despite the fact that they added drop
boxes out over the over the last
election cycle before the pandemic there
are a bunch of emergency drop boxes put
in place
for the pandemic despite the fact that
in most counties more people will be
voting in the future
doesn't matter jen sack is just going to
put out this lie
the georgia legislation is built on a
lie
uh it's there was no widespread fraud in
the 2020 election
uh georgia's top republican election
officials have acknowledged that
repeatedly in interviews
uh and what there was however was
record-setting turnout
especially by voters of color so instead
what we're seeing here isn't
for politicians who didn't like the
outcome uh they're not changing their
policies uh to win more votes they're
changing the rules to exclude
more voters and we certainly see the
circumstances she's just a damn liar
they are not trying to exclude voters
this is just a lie there's no evidence
this is going to result in the voter
surprise she says that this is built on
the lie that there was voter fraud
okay you know it's a bigger lie than
voter fraud and voter irregularity which
actually does occur
you know it's a bigger fraud voter
suppression can she show evidence that
anybody has suppressed the vote
seriously like any statistical evidence
any person who says they tried to vote
and they were wrongly rejected because
that's a federal lawsuit right there
can she demonstrate like any evidence of
that of course not so she lies but
here's the problem there's blow back to
this and again
just like with the border the biden
administration is beginning to realize
that their policies are not all that
popular that biden was elected to be not
alive he was not elected to be
particularly animate
he was not elected to be a mover and a
shaker he was elected to stand there
if he can that was his entire mandate
okay so
if they realize they're out over their
skis with regard to the
with regard to the border policy they're
also beginning to realize that they are
out over their skis with regards to how
far they went with this georgia law
there's a brand new poll out for morning
consult it shows that a plurality of
americans actually support georgia's new
election law
42 of americans say that they support
georgia's election law compared to 36
percent
who say that they don't support
georgia's election law
and if you look at the actual stats with
regard to
independence for example self-depre
self-described independence what you see
is that some 38 of self-described
independents say they like the law
compared to only 29
who say that they don't like the law
it's only among democrats
that people say that they are not a fan
of the law
so democrats are losing this argument
despite all of their political
propaganda
and you know what's even more unpopular
there's new polling data out it shows
americans do not like
the biden administration bullying mlb
into moving the all-star game
from atlanta to denver based on lies
about the georgia law
and you can tell that this is starting
to hit home again there's that wiley
coyote look
in joe biden's eyes as he realizes that
that acme rocket just ran out of fuel
and he's over the cliff
here is joe biden yesterday he's being
asked about moving sporting events from
georgia because it turns out the masters
is being held
now okay and the masters takes place
every year at augusta national
augusta national one of the great
sporting places in america one of the
great golf courses
on planet earth and so joe biden was
asked a very simple question you were in
favor of
mlb moving the all-star game are you in
favor of canceling the masters because
georgia passed a law that you don't like
and that you've been lying about and
here is joe biden
trying slowly to hobble away from his
own position
on whether corporations should boycott
states that do things democrats don't
like
it is reassuring to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move
out of georgia the people who need the
help the most
people who are making hourly wages
sometimes get hurt the most oh yeah well
you know what would have been nice is if
you had said that up front as opposed to
just going on espn and saying it's great
that mlb
is considering moving the all-star game
so basically he's acknowledging now that
what he did is wrong
he's acknowledging now that pushing
corporations to move their businesses
outside of states has some pretty solid
unintended consequences particularly for
populations that may have voted democrat
cobb county
atlanta is a democratic area okay so he
hurt his friends and now he's upset that
he hurt his friends
by the way this also works the other way
it turns out that if you decide that
you're going to politicize every
corporation
then people are simply going to take the
other side of that and they are going to
oppose
those corporations you can also sense
the biden administration feels that it
has been trapped here because if you are
encouraging corporations to stop
doing business with places like georgia
what do you do with places like china
because it turns out america is an awful
lot of business with china it turns out
that the
biden administration policy toward china
has been extremely
extremely friendly compared to the trump
administration policy
and so biden has been asked repeatedly
so is jen saki about moving the olympics
and their first response was well you
know we that that's really the us
olympic committee it's really up to them
well now
they understand that they look like
hypocrites so here was the state
department spokesperson yesterday saying
yeah no we are considering a beijing
olympics boycott first of all bullcrap
second of all if they do it it's only
because they've trapped themselves here
you seem to suggest on the olympics that
the u.s is
in consultations with allies discussing
whether to
consider or plan some sort of joint
boycott is that the case
well it is something that uh we
certainly wish to discuss
uh in that um uh it is certainly
something that we understand that uh a
coordinated approach
um will be not only in our interest um
but also um in the interests of our uh
allies and partners uh so this is one of
the issues um
that is on the agenda um both now and
going forward
and when we have something to announce
we will be sure to do that okay so that
is them attempting to kick the cans down
the road again there's that look in the
eyes they all understand that they've
been trapped into this the same
administration that is currently pushing
to give money to the iranian terrorist
government is saying that corporations
shouldn't do business in georgia
but oh by the way maybe they should
actually do business in georgia the
media is in the same trap
the the thing that the the media are
respected by the american people for is
not the thing they want to do
and the thing that democrats were
elected to do is not the thing they want
to do they were elected to be not donald
trump
they were not elected to be radical the
democrats can't stop themselves they're
going to be radical and the american
people are going to backlash against
them it is going to happen
in 2022 it's not going to be a good year
for democrats
okay and the same thing holds true for
the media the media
whatever level of baseline respect
people were willing to give to the media
was rooted in the idea that they were
going to actually cover the news
not manufacture the news but they don't
want a man
they don't want to cover the news they
want to be activists this is what they
would like to do with their lives if you
talk to journalists they see themselves
as quote unquote making the world a
better place not by reporting the news
by crafting the narrative well the
problem is that this leads them into
dead ends where they don't actually
report the news they manufacture the
news wholesale
the most obvious example over the past
little while being
60 minutes completely manufacturing out
of whole cloth the story that ron
desantis
allowed publix to distribute the covet
vaccine because he was bribed by the
by the public's people which is utterly
crazy i mean so crazy that the mayor of
palm beach
county who is a democrat the mayor of
palm beach was like uh no that's not
true
and he said i told you guys that it was
bs and you guys ignored it
we'll get to that in just one second
because the blowback is beginning
against the media too
again the story here is that the
blowback is coming democrats
are overshooting the mark and we are
only a few months in the media are
overshooting the mark corporations are
overshooting the mark the blowback is
coming
and i am here for it i am ready for it
and you should be too we'll get to that
in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that you need a great night's sleep
so my kids have been waking me up at all
hours as they always do
the other night my baby little girl who
is a sweetie she's a squishy baby that
squishy baby
decided it would be fun to wake up at 5
15 in the morning and just scream her
heart out
well she was fine my sleep was not
except that when i was sleeping i was
sleeping
on my pillow ah yes my pillow that is
some solid stuff
right there by now you've all heard me
talk about the wonders of my pillow
they've done it again they've introduced
my slippers the slippers took over two
years to develop they're designed to
wear indoors
outdoors all day long my slippers are
made with the pillow foam and impact gel
to help prevent fatigue and made with
quality leather suede
i can tell you firsthand they're super
comfortable i've received them and i'm
wearing them
pretty much all the time the whole
family's gonna want them for a limited
time my pillow is offering 40
off their new my slippers that is 40 off
so i've got the sheets the pillows and
slippers from my pillow like all their
other products comfort
is key go to mypillow.com click on the
radio listener square use promo code
daily wire
you will also get deep discounts on all
my pillow products including the giza
dream bed sheets the my pillow mattress
topper the my pillow towel sets or call
800-951-7163
use promo code dailywire visit
mypillow.com right now
or call 800-951-7163
to get started okay so as i say 60
minutes just lied about
rhonda santas and it's just a lie what
they said which is that for a hundred
thousand dollar donation to a super pac
that ron desantis decided to allow you
know the most
the most prevalent grocery chain in the
state
to hand out the vaccines that it was the
bribe that did it not you know local
officials saying you know what'd be
great is if our grocery store pharmacies
could actually give out the vaccine
that was a lie it was pretty obviously a
lie 60 minutes
completely jobbed desantis here i mean
they absolutely
chopped apart a press conference he did
in which a 60 minutes reporter asked him
some questions
they just cut out his actual answer
heroes desantis going hard after the
media
these are smear merchants that's why
nobody trusts
corporate media they are a disaster
in what they're doing they knew what
they were doing
was a lie i knew what they were doing
was a lie everybody here knows what they
were doing is a lie
they know that we know they're lying and
yet they continue to lie
and they lied and they lied and they
lied
we offered them the information and they
declined
to interview the key people because they
didn't want to let go of the narrative
well guess what there's going to be
consequences for that
okay and there should be consequences
for that but the media are too committed
to this path they can't stop themselves
you see if they ever admit that they got
this one wrong
just like if they ever admit that they
got any of these stories wrong the
kavanaugh story the covington catholic
story if they ever admit that they just
blew it
then they have to admit who they really
are it's not that the journalists are
bad at their job it's they're very good
at their job it's just their job is not
journalism
their job is the narrative their job is
activism they are very good activists
and they are very bad journalists
their job what you think their job is is
not what they think their job is same
thing with biden his job was just to be
there and be not bear
just to be barely animate but he thinks
his job is to be this radical activist
fdr lbj character
people don't like that people also are
not liking what the media are all about
but they can't admit that what they're
doing is not journalism otherwise
people might notice that what they're
doing is not journalism so instead 60
minutes put out this statement quote
when florida state data revealed people
of color were vaccinated at a much lower
rate than their wealthier neighbors
60 minutes reported the facts
surrounding the vaccine's rollout which
is controlled by the governor
we requested and conducted interviews
with dozens of sources and authorities
involved we requested an interview with
governor desantis he declined i wonder
why
i wonder why he declined an interview
with you maybe because he thought that
you were going to hatchet job him
we spoke to state emergency management
director jared moskowitz twice he
declined to be interviewed on camera for
our story until well after our deadline
the idea we ignored their perspective is
untrue counter to a statement yesterday
we also spoke on the record with palm
beach county mayor david kerner
for over 50 years the facts reported by
60 minutes have often stirred debate and
prompted strong reactions
our story sunday night speaks for itself
my favorite part here is where they say
they spoke to the palm beach county
mayor but they didn't bother quoting him
like he told them straight up your
story's crap didn't matter they reported
it anyway so 60 minutes
tripling down on that story because to
do anything else see people on the right
why are they
because to do anything else is to admit
what they are they can't do that
they are too far over the cliff same
thing is about to happen
in in corporate america so corporate
america has decided to fully embrace
the woke i mean on an enormous level
in an unending level they're going to
embrace the woke through and through
and they're going to pay the price they
don't realize
and i think some of the politicians
realize because politicians tend to have
their finger in the window anyways when
the wind changes they they can feel it
and those in the media also can follow
what's going on in twitter so they
understand when the wind changes
they're not going to do anything about
it but they at least understand when the
wind changes corporate america
are a bunch of people in suits who just
want to make money
and those people in suits sitting in
corporate boardrooms generally do not
have their finger in the wind which is
why you can have
a garbage organization like media
matters get 10 of its friends to call a
company
and then the company thinking that that
is the win not understanding that's not
even a breeze they will immediately
shift cores
right there they are oversensitive on
the one hand and slow to move on the
other corporate america
but when they do move they're usually
late and unpopular because americans are
predisposed not to particularly like
big corporations especially when they
start throwing their weight around in
areas
that are not within their purview it
turns out that corporations engaging in
ultra crepitarianism which is where
they're
engaged in stuff that is not within
their purview that's becoming more and
more common
at the behest of the democratic party
and they are doing so because one of the
great lies in america
is that corporations are free market
institutions they are not
they are profit-seeking institutions
there is a difference if you are a rent
seeker
i mean iran makes this distinction in
atlas shrugged so i mean it's not like
there's anything new if you are seeking
rent
from the federal government that doesn't
mean you're pro-free market you can be
very profit driven and still be
a an anti-free market institution this
happens all the time
if you have a monopoly granted by the
government you're a profit-seeking
institution
that does not mean that you are pro-free
markets well this is true
more and more of our big corporations
which also hope to engage in regulatory
capture they have basically two
priorities one is
don't get punished by the democrats and
two is capture the regulatory heights
so that you can re you can change the
regulations and the regulatory
structures so that they impact you
and they hurt you some but they hurt
everybody at the bottom of the skill way
more
the goal of big corporations is not just
to succeed in their space in a free
market space
their goal is to kill their competition
and if they can use government to do
that
they will do it if if the question is we
take no hit
our competition takes no hit and our
competition taking no hit means they
might compete with us
or we promote regulations that
harm us a little bit but harm our
opponents a lot they will always take
the ladder
that's the reason why you saw so many of
these big companies coming out in favor
of net neutrality for example because it
helped
it didn't really hurt them it helped
them a little bit and it really hurt
anybody who's attempting to enter the
market space
it's the reason why you're constantly
seeing large corporations seeking
regulatory structures
they have large companies they have big
legal teams who are capable of complying
with those regulatory structures so
never you fear this is not
about corporations gaining some level of
woke principle it's not about that it's
about the incentive structure the
incentive structure right now
for corporations is to go woke because
they believe that democrats will leave
them alone
and eat them last or we'll work hand in
glove with them if they do everything
the democrats say it's really
short-sighted
because it it's a weird strategy
long-term to side with the side
that believes that you are a blight on
american life
i mean elizabeth warren if she utterly
would break up amazon tomorrow but
that's not stopping jeff bezos from
coming out in favor
of a bunch of corporate tax hikes he
says we support the biden
administration's focus on making bold
investments in american infrastructure
bezos is a democrat of course he's also
the head of the
washington post or he owns the
washington post that's not a surprise
in any way shape or form he says we
support the biden administration's focus
on making bold investments in american
infrastructure
both democrats and republicans have
supported infrastructure in the past
it's the right time to work together to
make this happen
we recognize this investment will
require concessions from all sides both
on the specifics of what's included
as well as how it gets paid for we're
supportive of a rise in the corporate
tax rate
we look forward to congress and the
administration coming together to find
the right
balanced solution that maintains or
enhances us competitiveness yet bullcrap
i'll tell you what jeff bezos is in
favor of he's in favor of joe biden
leaving him alone
he's in favor of joe biden using that
corporate tax rate to crack down
on other less large corporations amazon
will survive and increase in the
corporate tax you know who won't
people who run small businesses and run
on very thin margins that's who's going
to pay
jeff bezos knows that you think the
american people are going to react
to these giant corporations getting in
bed with the democrats by
somehow swinging behind democratic
policy i think not all that's going to
happen
is that the base of support that some
corporations have on the right is going
to dissipate there'll be a lot of people
on the right
who say okay you know what bernie wants
you out of existence
have at it man you decided you want to
be with bernie and you want to be with
biden
we leave you to their tender mercies you
want to get in bed with them we're not
going to stop
you from getting good and effed like
that's not that's not a thing we are
going to stand in the way of anymore
because if you've decided that you wish
to promote their agenda
you can enjoy their tender mercies and
it's not just
jeff bezos and amazon it is it is every
major corporation american life they are
cruising for a bruising if they decide
that they're going to go woke here
because they will go broke and then they
will be sitting there on the side of the
road crying to themselves why
why is it that these democrats that we
trusted have decided that they want to
force us to unionize and they want to
increase the minimum wage on us and they
want to take us apart piecemeal
yeah it may have hurt your competitors
in the short term but here's the thing
free market financial structures are the
ones that you became rich under if you
decide to dismantle those don't be
surprised when you find yourself in the
crosshairs
okay we'll get some more of this in just
a second but first why the heck would
you be using
a pair of earbuds that have wires
connected to them this is not
2003. instead you need a great pair of
wireless earbuds
there's only one pair of wireless
earbuds i actually trust those are the
people over at raycon these wireless
earbuds are just
spectacular whether you're catching up
on your favorite news podcast or binging
an audiobook or powering through your
workout with a pumped up playlist
a pair of raycons in your ears can make
all the difference
no dangling wires no stems to get in
your way raycons come in a range of
stylish colors
always with a comfortable in-ear fit for
a more discreet look raycons are built
to perform anywhere anytime with water
and sweat resistant construction
and bluetooth that pairs quickly and
seamlessly they've got enough battery
life for six hours of playtime which
means you can unplug for quite a while
the best part
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds starting
at half the price of other premium audio
brands raycon is offering 15
off all their products from my listeners
here's what you've got to do to go get
it go to buy raycon.com
that's it you get 15 off your entire
raycon order feel free to grab a pair
and a spare 15 percent off
at byraycon dot com slash bend that's
buy raycon
dot com slash ben go check them out
right now by raycon dot com
slash man i love mine because they fit
my ear perfectly you can customize them
to do so go check them out right now buy
raycon.com for the best pair
of wireless earbuds on the market
already in just a second
we'll get to more of corporate america
going woke this is the prey
the backlash is going to be tremendous
on all this stuff as we return
from eastern passover it's important to
reflect on the impact these holidays
have on our faith the impact judeo
christian values have on our culture
more and more the left wants to erase
these values replace them with their own
pseudomorality that's why we've launched
a brand new talk show with canada zones
one of the fiercest protectors of
conservative values and free speech
there is go behind the headlines and
twitter fights see candace as herself
funny political insightful watch her
host lively discussion panels and
exclusive interviews with an always
exciting round of guess
candace is the first daily wire show to
appear in front of a live studio
audience
it's an element that's basically never
been seen in conservative online media
cements our commitment to fighting for
the culture whatever the left does
we can do better and we are bringing you
candace every friday
9pm eastern 8 pm central at
dailywire.com and get the audio podcast
canvas on apple spotify wherever you
listen to your podcast
if you need some candace owens in your
podcast feed look no further head on
over to apple podcast or spotify
subscribe today be sure to leave a five
star review if you like what you hear
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
corporate america's embrace of wokeness
it's going to boomerang on them in a
major way and it's happening across the
spectrum because again
these ships are slow to turn these
corporate ships they're very slow to
turn and once they've decided to steer
into the head storm that is wokeness
it's going to take them a while to get
out of it and not easily because they've
decided to surrender themselves to the
alligator hoping they will be eaten last
this leads to the most bizarre corporate
endorsement of wokeness of the day
that is united airlines united airlines
put out a video suggesting
that they are going to ensure that half
of their pilots are going to be women or
people of color
now this is crazy it is crazy because if
there is one job in america there are
many jobs in america where
skills should be like the soul qualifies
qualification qualifying detail
in fact every job in america i believe
skill should be the only qualifying
detail i don't think that race or sex or
sexual none of that should matter can
you do the job is the only question i
want answered
in every job scenario but if you're
going to pick jobs
where skill is like the only thing that
matters
this would be one of them like personal
life experience does not matter
when you're talking about can you land a
plane safely
and this is like it to me it's like a
heart surgeon do i care about the
personal life experiences of my heart
surgeon
absolutely not absolutely not
but united has now made it its goal to
say that 50
of its trained pilots are going to be
women or people of color so pilot stacey
abrams
on the line from united airlines here we
go from united airlines
departure review is looking at the plate
everything checks good we're going to
just nab it out then airplane setup for
us to actually apply navigation all the
way out for the hour now
by 2030 we plan to train 5 000 pilots we
plan for 50
of admitted students to be women or
people of color
partner organizations will help identify
and recruit top
talent and now they've been trying this
in silicon valley for years it turns out
it's a giant fail
the reason it's a giant fail is because
people are either qualified or
unqualified
to be engineers and people are either
qualified or unqualified to be pilots
if you are changing the qualifications
from can you fly a plane to what color
is your skin and do you have
a vagina although i understand that dad
is not even a qualification to be a
woman anymore so
do you self-identify as a woman or
are you a person with more melanin in
your skin if those are your
qualifications for your pilots
number one you're going to be subjected
to a discrimination lawsuit like nothing
you've ever seen
and number two i am never flying your
airline are you out of your damned mind
why would i get on a plane where the
only thing i know about the pilot
is that the pilot may have been select i
have a one in two chance of having a
pilot selected not on the basis of skill
alone
that's crazy i didn't find that you'd be
crazy to fly that airline
what what are you doing what are you
saying i mean
matt walsh made the uh made the
hilarious point he said
you know it turns out that a certain
percentage of americans are blind
and a huge percentage of americans are
elderly we should have a certain number
united needs to make sure that a certain
number of pilots are qualified
despite being blind and 100 years old it
needs to happen
or alternatively you could not collapse
to the woke idiocy culture
but again our corporate culture has
decided that this is the wave of the
future
they are going to be sorely mistaken
they are going to feel the backlash in a
serious way not just because people stop
flying their airlines but because
competitors will arise who don't follow
this garbage
also because again your protectors on
the in
on the corporate side should be neutral
rules
that foster free markets that of course
is where you succeeded in the first
place
if you decide to undermine those neutral
rules of free marketplaces
by going for the corporatist
the the corporatist crony capitalist
dollars that the democrats are offering
you
get ready man they are not it this is so
short-sighted it is so unbelievably
short-sighted mitch mcconnell put that
point out he said you know corporate
america you might want to not do this
because there are going to be some
consequences for you
my warning if you will to corporate
america is to stay out of politics
it's not what you're designed for
and don't be intimidated by the left
into taking up causes
that put you right in the middle of one
of america's greatest political
debates that's that's my admonition and
delta and the other coca-cola and the
other companies that
basically
responded to this partisan appeal
are doing the same thing you know
republicans drink coca-cola too
okay and that that of course is a
paraphrasal line that michael jordan
once used in the 1990s the republicans
buy sneakers too it's true
we do and i am not in favor of boycotts
as a general rule i think it's better if
we were able to just patronize whichever
businesses
we think make the best products but so
long as they're going to spit in our
face
well there'll be a lot of republicans
who say nope we're not doing that
anymore if harry's razors decides that
it's going to withdraw advertising from
some of our shows
well get ready we'll launch our razer
brand and then we'll go right after
the same audience that you advertised in
order to gain access to
okay this works both ways they're going
too far the backlash is coming the
backlash is coming by the way with
regard to the the black lives matter
movements propaganda about police
the backlash is coming because it turns
out that crime rates have been rising
dramatically around the united states
the us according to cnn saw a
significant crime rise across major
cities in 2020
according to cnn major american cities
so a 33 increase in homicide last year
okay that is because of the attempt to
absolutely hamstring the cops and make
it impossible for them to do their jobs
you think people are going to go along
to get along on these particular issues
tom cotton is getting dragged through
them by the senator from arkansas
because he tweeted out we have a major
under incarceration problem in america
and it's getting worse
and we were like well yeah we already
incarcerated a lot of people the
question isn't how many people we
incarcerate the question is how many of
those people are innocent
answer not a lot and how many people who
are guilty are out walking the streets
answer some there's a very simple
question to ask when it comes to under
incarceration versus over-incarceration
it is not percentage of people
incarcerated it's percentage of people
who committed crimes in jail
that's the only question i care about if
you committed a murder
i don't care if we have more people in
jail than other countries you should be
in jail you committed a murder
so tom cotton on the numbers is correct
if there's a 33
increase in homicide that means too few
people are in jail
at least when it comes to homicide okay
but it doesn't matter because
again the left can't stop itself in
corporate america that ship can't be
turned
in the media they cannot re-steer
themselves because they have dedicated
themselves to activism the biden
administration
can't turn away from its own radicalism
and the criminal justice system the
black lives matter movement can't steer
away from its own radicalism this is how
you end up with videos of blm activists
saying that cities will burn if derek
schauvin isn't convicted how do you
think this is going to play
you think he's going to play in america
you think this is really going to go
well for you
here is this blm activist if george
floyd's murderer
is not sentenced just know that all hell
is going to break loose
don't be surprised when buildings on
fire
okay so here's the thing as i've been
pointing out this whole time and i think
most people
who have a brain are noticing is that
this shalvin case
is not clear cod not only is it not
clear cut yesterday happened to be a
particularly bad day for the prosecution
in the in the derek chalvin murder case
with regard to george floyd
there are a bunch of witnesses who were
interviewed yesterday and it did not
turn out well for the prosecution in
fact it turned out so not well for the
prosecution that one of the witnesses
the prosecution called
the defense announced they wanted to
recall the witness as a defense witness
that's how badly it went for the
prosecution you know the prosecution is
doing a crappy job when they call a
witness
and the defense cross-examines the guy
and they're like you know what we like
you so much we want you back
on our side like that ain't good the
state called
a minneapolis police department
lieutenant named johnny mercer who's a
use of force trainer
and the and the prosecution asked him a
bunch of questions about whether shalvin
was using approved use of force
procedures
but then eric nelson who is the defense
attorney began asking questions
related to mercel's time as a street cop
this according to legal insurrection.com
he's been
doing good job analyzing this on a
day-to-day level
nelson asked questions related to
mercel's time as a street cop with a
particular emphasis on the tendencies of
suspects being subject to arrest to come
up with all kinds of nonsense about why
they shouldn't be arrested that day
dangerous job being a police officer yes
are people unhappy about being arrested
very rarely are they happy said mercel
do suspects frequently engage in a wide
variety of behaviors to avoid arrest
including fighting
arguing and making excuses yes they do
answered mercel indeed when asked if he
himself had ever disbelieved a suspect's
claim of a medical emergency
in an apparent effort to avoid arrest
mercel answered he had personally done
so
all of this undercuts the part of the
prosecution narrative that is relying on
floyd's purported pleas and excuses
about claustrophobia
and anxiety and crying out for his
mother perhaps that's real but a
reasonable officer
has to consider maybe it's an effort to
avoid arrest
nelson also once again put the use of
pressure and body weight techniques in a
favorable favorable light
the state wants to present chauvin's
knee in a negative light as deadly
mechanical asphyxiation or as a blood
choke
as attested to by this other witness
derek williams in fact however the use
of pressure and body weight to restrain
a suspect was adopted by the mpd because
it was a less
intense use of force than prior practice
of using strikes either bare-handed or
batons or even with weighted gloves to
compel compliance
mercile concurred the take-home message
for the jury
is that shelvin's knee far from being a
public execution in a public street was
a lesser
force than would otherwise have been
required
so bottom line is this prosecution is
not particularly going well
for the prosecution nelson explored with
mercer whether there were circumstances
in which it would be appropriate for an
officer to maintain a neck restraint for
a substantial period of time mercel said
yes
sometimes to maintain the neck restraint
for however long it took ems to arrive
as nelson merciled answered that he
personally
had maintained restraint on suspects for
the duration required
for ems to arrive the state's own use of
force expert testified on cross he
personally had engaged in the exact same
activity that chalvin is currently being
demonized for
that is not a good day for the state as
legal insurrection points out
so again it was just a very very bad day
for the prosecution the reason that i'm
pointing
this out is because what you're hearing
from the media is that this is gonna
the shelvin doesn't get convicted it's a
referendum on american racism cops are
all bad
fewer cops on the street you think this
isn't going to backfire it's going to
backfire
it absolutely will backfire on the left
because
all they would have to do is say listen
we're going to look at the facts of the
case and we have a jury system for a
reason they can't do that
they have to say that this is deep
american racism regardless of whatever
the evidence shows and again it wasn't
just that it went badly
for that state's witness there's another
state's witness mpd officer nicole
mckenzie who's the medical support
coordinator according to legal
insurrection
mckenzie did really poorly on direct
the prosecutor had mackenzie testify
about how officers had a duty of care to
suspects that chevin had cpr another
training that would qualify him to
provide emergency care and that such
care must be provided by the officer
even if an ambulance had already been
called isn't it true nelson then asked
mckenzie that you train
officers to consider not just the
suspect but the totality of the scene
she said yes
isn't it true that police officers have
a competing duty of safety to themselves
partners bystanders paramedics
to the point that if the scene is unsafe
if the officers haven't already
announced a code for all safe emts will
stage a distance away
until they are told safety has been
achieved yes said mackenzie isn't it
true safety concerns might not come from
the suspect from
but from the crowd yes okay and by the
way
the mob was there shouting at i mean
that's why we have tape
shouting at calvin the entire time which
prevents the mts from getting it
all of this generates at least a picture
of reasonable doubt
all of this pictures at least the
possibility of reasonable doubt
so it's you know none of this is going
particularly well for the state
and if this results in more riots if
this results in more calls for the end
of policing in america it ain't going to
go well for the left either
the left is overreaching on every area
in american life right now you knew it
was coming it is coming
and the backlash is going to be
extremely strong so it's not just the
areas of the white house or the media or
corporate america or even the law where
the left
feels it's oats they feel ascendant but
the backlash is coming it's in the area
of culture they're going
way way too far in the culture so for
example marvel
for some ungodly reason for some reason
that no one can comprehend
decided that it would be a wonderful
idea to have ta-nehisi coates write
captain america comics this makes
no sense at all captain america's
character is a character who was
frozen in the 1940s
and then reanimated years and years
later he's supposed to be a refugee from
1940s america ra rob that's why he's
captain america
right he's supposed to stand for all of
the values of the united states
among them are not america is a deeply
racist country
plagued by by by structural
injustices america's rooted in evil and
racism and cruelty
so to have somebody write captain
america you might want to pick somebody
who actually likes the country
who likes the declaration of
independence and the constitution
somebody who doesn't think america is
evil from its inception you know
somebody who doesn't think like the
60-19 project but no
marvel decided it was not good enough to
have tan haasey coates write the black
panther comics
he had to also write the captain america
comics which is nuts okay ta-nehisi
coates is a person
who said in an interview with the with
with the new yorker i believe
he said that on 9 11 he sat on the top
of his brooklyn
apartment building slightly stoned
watched 911 happen watched the planes go
into the buildings
and people throwing themselves from the
80th story of the world trade center
down to their deaths watched the towers
collapse and felt nothing
that's how much he hates the country
tannehassee codes right that is
something he said openly and
and that was considered okay because
after all there's been racial evil in
america
and tanahasi codes who's gotten
extraordinarily wealthy and
extraordinarily famous by talking about
how terrible america is he should write
the captain america comment
and comic so on its face this is an
absurdity it's
like having noam chomsky write superman
right truth justice in the american way
except that america is an imperialist
invader that is constantly destroying
countries around the world yeah get no
arm to write it
makes for noam chomsky should write
superman ta-nehisi coates writing
captain america is the same thing so
it's stupid on its face
but it's not just stupid what they
actually allowed ta-nehisi coates to do
here
is portray red skull who's the villain
in the
captain america and people say why do
you even bother talking about the
culture because
more people in america engage with the
culture than engage in politics
culture is important culture is upstream
of politics and when you start
mainstreaming complete
and utter nasty and slanderous bull crap
about not only the country but about
anybody who disagrees with you
into discourse that is meant mainly for
teenagers you know what you get a worse
country
they're going to push too hard here they
really are so tana hussey coates put out
this comic the comic shows red skull
recruiting people online
uh you know where this is going don't
you recruiting uh recruiting people
online red skull right who's a nazi
right red skull
as a character is a nazi who had his
face burned off and he's like and he's
now a mutant
okay and here is the panel it says the
red skull
it is a picture of the red skull on a
laptop
and it says 10 rules for life next to
his face
who do you think that's supposed to be
10 rules for life
could that possibly be jordan peterson
just to reiterate the point just to make
sure that you know it's supposed to be
jordan peterson
it then says in the corner chaos and
order
because of course jordan's books are all
about
leading a finding order within the chaos
right these are terms that jordan
frequently uses and he talks about
feminism and so just to make sure
it says the feminist trap right the
feminist trap so you're supposed to know
that this is in fact the that this is in
fact
jordan peterson and not only that
he he then has a reference to carl lugar
who of course
is a is a deeply famous anti-semite
viewed as sort of a model for
nazism in the pre-nazi era he's sort of
the proto-nazi
so the idea is that jordan is a nazi
okay that's absurd on its face it's
absurd it's slanderous
honest to god it's it's it's disgusting
because ta-nehisi codes is just a damned
liar
so i know jordan i've read pretty much
everything jordan's written
i've watched many of his videos as you
have i'm sure the notion that he is
pro-nazi is insane it is insipid and it
is ridiculous
but the red skull is a nazi and is
actually jordan peterson in this comic
directed toward teenagers and then
there's this other conversation that
happens about how red skull
is recruiting people in in which captain
america says
it's the same for all of them young men
weak looking for purpose
i found the flag you found the badge
they found the skull
he tells them what they've always longed
to hear that they are secretly great
that the whole world is against them
that if they're truly men they'll fight
back
and bingo that's their purpose that's
what they live for and that's what
they'll die for so if you tell
young men that they have a purpose in
the world if you try to tell young men
not to pity themselves and be losers if
you tell them to make their bed this is
this makes you a nazi like red skull
tanahasi coats writing that
in a comic book our culture the wokeness
in comics by the way has been going on
for a long time
dc did this too dc tried to make
superman into an anti-police figure
they had a batman comic in which batman
was railing against the cops not just
the corrupt gotham city cops but like
cops generally and about racial
injustice and all this kind of stuff
marvel has now trotted out a gay teen
captain america and i was like this
this is not a surprise but to have
ta-nehisi coates mainlining
all of this crap into like the captain
america comic does tell you something
about where our culture is
and our entire cultural infrastructure
has been taken over by people who are
completely removed
from the everyday lives of the people
with whom they are supposed to be
talking because
your typical comic consumer is not
somebody who believes that jordan
peterson is the red skull
just like your typical consumer of
television is not somebody who believes
that we should be
spending our days fretting over how to
turn girls into boys and boys into girls
when they are young people
when they are tiny and yet this is the
direction in which our culture is moving
by the way there are some soft-hearted
republicans and i shouldn't say
soft-hearted soft-headed because they
are not soft-hearted
in fact what they are promoting here is
really not soft-hearted soft-headed
republicans asa hutchinson
the governor of arkansas comes to mind
who's thoroughly shellacked by tucker
carlson
last night on his show as he should have
been because he decided that he was
going to veto a bill which was then
overridden by the arkansas legislature
the bill prohibited the use of
transgender
medicine on children below the age of 17
i believe
and he vetoed that and he said well you
know we shouldn't be getting government
involved in these areas
oh you mean protecting children from the
destruction of their bodies
by by pseudo-medical professionals
who don't know the first thing about
what they're talking about and are
simply following woke precepts with
regard to gender
in any case our culture has been
promoting that that's that's why we
ended up in this situation
so you have sophia bush who says that
you know we are
that we that if you don't allow child
sex changes that is talent amount to
murder
sophia bush tweeted out voting rights
are under attack the gop has launched
over 250
voter suppression bills just a lie
they're trying to kill democracy it's
the new jim crow
it's against all we stand for okay
that's lie number one put that to the
side because the left is always
promoting the lie that republicans are
engaged in voter suppression
even though that is obviously not true
then she tweeted out
trans kids are under attack across the
country ar just banned them from
accessing health care this is tantamount
to murder
kids will tell us who they are it's our
job to support them not demonize or harm
them
um okay first of all the baseline notion
that kids will tell you who they are is
the biggest
load of crap i have ever heard in my
life i have three children
all under the age of eight if my
four-year-old tells me
he is a robot guess what he is not a
robot you know what it would make me
if i said okay you're a robot it would
make me a deeply irresponsible and
moronic parent
it is your job to civilize your child it
is not your child your child's job
to proclaim their authentic self to you
at four and for you to take everything
that they say super seriously because
that's idiotic
you are smarter than a four-year-old and
if you're not you shouldn't be a parent
but beyond that this is just a lie she
says that arkansas
banned trans kids from accessing
healthcare no arkansas banned trans
arkansas banned all children from being
experimented on by doctors
using hormone therapies to block puberty
and mutilate their bodies that's what
arkansas just banned
but don't worry if you watch our culture
this is not just opposition
this is the position it's a position
that is parroted by the entire
mainstream media
which uses the exact same phraseology
with regard to the arkansas bill the
idea
is that if you as a state don't allow
doctors to practice
medical chicanery on children that if
you don't allow doctors
to mutilate children with hormone
therapy again you don't know the
long-term cost of using puberty blockers
on an eight-year-old that if you do this
then this somehow makes you a murderer a
murderer
whereas presumably a better person if
you say a seven-year-old is gender
confused because we keep preaching to
them in public school that they might be
a member of the opposite sex and they
don't know what that means because it
doesn't make any internal sense
and also they don't know what it means
because they are children so number one
if you're an adult you shouldn't know
what it means because it makes no sense
if you're a child you certainly
shouldn't know what it means because
you're stupid and it makes no sense
and yet the idea here from our entire
media and from our entire cultural
sphere
is that if you stand in the way of this
that you are somehow the bad guy the
backlash to this is going to happen it
is going to be tremendous
there will be a backlash to all of this
there'll be a backlash to the coarsening
of our culture
i mean the and the left is begging for
it at this point because what they want
is the shock value
right they want to push the boundaries
and then when you notice that they're
pushing the boundaries
when you notice that they're doing
things just for shock value then they
say why are you even offended look at
you being offended
yeah when you when you purposefully do
things that are offensive i am offended
it turns out i am offended when you
create sneakers that are designed to
promote satan i'm slightly offended
forgive me if i don't want that being
promoted to children as louis
x has been doing so little sex this uh
this
musical star for no obvious reason to me
lulumos x
who is now openly gay and came out was
big big story
because obviously we have to treat it as
a huge story whenever any pop star comes
out as gay that's like 70
of pop stars at this point coming out as
some form of gender fluid
but in any case wilma's x came out as
gay and uh and then he put out this
ridiculous song montero call me by your
name it is a
crappy song i mean an unbelievably bad
song but the entire music video
is about him literally having sex with
satan uh
who is male of course having sex with
satan
and then and then taking satan's crown
and
it's it's not even it's almost tired
because people have been doing this this
anti-religious crap since madonna was
writhing around as a foe
as a faux catholic back in the 1980s
and proclaiming that that she was like a
virgin touched for the very first time
in all of this and it really isn't all
that transgressive it's kind of faux
transgressive
but the fact that lil nassak's has
appeared on like sesame street
and half of his crowd or people under 15
probably
is somewhat disturbing so little masek
tweeted out
y'all told a 19 year olds who had just
escaped the lowest point of his life
that he would never have a hit again
no one actually said that you told him
to stop while he's ahead nope
he could have gave up but four
multi-platinum songs and two number ones
later he's still here thank you to my
team
and my fans i love you so this is the
number one song in the country
you think that the left isn't pushing
too far in the culture you think there
won't be a backlash
okay here is the number one song in the
in the country
it is little mousex dressed up as a
stripper
swiveling down a stripper pull into hell
where he proceeds to engage in anal sex
with satan this is
first of all the song is just crap i
mean like if this is unmemorable
it is a ripoff obviously of the title of
the movie call me by your name
like okay he's stripping down into hell
swiveling down and like all right is
what you want from your culture this is
what you're gonna get
from your culture and now he's about to
enter the palace of satan
and uh he is uh then going to engage in
various unspeakable acts with satan
and give satan a lap dance then have sex
with satan
and uh and then he's going to take
satan's crown at the end because
obviously this is what we should all
aspire to
uh is to become satan which is the end
of this video
now again free country do what you want
but if you think that the height of our
culture is
whap and this
and you think that americans are just
going to be like yeah it's all good
keep marketing this crap to our kids
please please keep telling us how deeply
important all this is and how empowering
all of it is and how it's going to make
for a wonderful fulfilling life for
children
man you guys keep pushing this way in
the culture you keep pushing this way on
the left
by the way i just should note here that
the the sort of take here which is that
you can act like garbage
so long as you are of a sexual
orientation minority is ridiculous
you know how many gay people there are
who don't act like this in music videos
virtually all of them but you want to
promulgate
you know some pretty nasty messages
about
about folks this is this is the way to
do it lil nassak's really doing
yeoman's work there on behalf of the gay
rights movement for some
odd reason in any case the point is
larger
and the point is the same the left is
overstepping its boundaries
there there some of them have realized
that biden's already realizing it
because he has his finger in the wind
more than most
the corporations haven't yet realized it
they will the cultural figures they
haven't yet realized it they're going to
there will be a backlash it's been too
long in coming and i'm very much
looking forward to the backlash i'm
looking forward to people
stopping their their monetary
patronization of these various
corporations i'm looking forward to
people turning off mtv
and and not listening to songs like this
in the future i'm looking forward to
alternatives
cropping up and if we have to have two
separate cultures and
and two separate ways of raising our
children and if we have to go our
separate ways maybe that's one solution
the other possibility here
is that the american people are not
going to be as
enthusiastic about all of this stuff as
everybody on the left is
and then when the backlash comes it's
going to come in a lot of political ways
that people on the left aren't
particularly fond of so get ready for it
all right we'll be back here today with
additional hour of content in the
meantime go check out the michael knoll
show on today's episode michael we'll be
talking about the double mutant
fourth wave of coronavirus it's not
happening that episode is available
right now i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam scievitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hera and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
the governor of arkansas defends the
chemical castration of kids
the mlb moves its all-star game out of
georgia to a whiter state with stricter
voting laws
and the experts warn of a double mutant
fourth wave of coronavirus check it out
on the michael knowles show